Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. What is the Chinese war like? Well, at least I know it isn't like wars in history books.
感谢您收听《往事并不如烟》。要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告连播、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢您收听《往事并不如烟》。如需加更节目、抢先体验、无广告连播以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是苹果播客应用，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。中国的战争是怎样的？至少我知道它和历史书上的战争不一样。
You know, those lucid, tidy maps of battles one used to study at school. The flanks like neat little cubes, the pincer movements working with mathematical precision, the reinforcements never failing to arrive. It isn't like that at all. War is bombing an already disused arsenal, missing it and killing a few old women. War is lying in a stable with a gangrenous leg. War is drinking hot water in a barn and worrying about one's wife. War is a handful of lost and terrified men in the mountains shooting at something moving in the undergrowth. War is waiting for days with nothing to do, shouting down a dead telephone, going without sleep or sex or a wash. War is untidy, inefficient, obscure, and largely a matter of chance.
你知道的，那些人们过去在学校里学到的清晰、整洁的战役地图。两翼就像整齐的小立方体，钳形攻势以数学般的精确度运作，增援部队从不失约。根本不是这样的。战争是轰炸一个本已废弃的军火库，结果炸偏了，炸死几个老太太。战争是带着坏疽的腿躺在马厩里。战争是在谷仓里喝着热水，担心着自己的妻子。战争是一群在山里迷路且惊恐万分的男人，向灌木丛中移动的黑影开枪。战争是无所事事地等待好几天，对着断了线的电话大喊大叫，连觉、性生活或洗澡都没有。战争是杂乱无章的、低效的、晦涩难懂的，而且很大程度上取决于运气。
So Tom, that was W.H. Auden, the great poet. And he was talking on the BBC in January 1939, having come back from China, about his experience of the Second World War in China, which of course had not started yet, according to the traditional chronology, because we think of World War II beginning in 1939. But it didn't, if you're in East Asia, did it? It absolutely did not. And the war between Japan and China, which breaks out in 1937. Well, or 1931. Well, we will have the chance to test that, but let's call it 1937 for now. Is it a kind of hideous prelude to the Second World War, or is it the opening stages of the Second World War? I mean, this horrendous conflict, which is so little known in the West, and yet it's so influential, not just on the course of the Second World War, but also, of course, on Chinese history right the way up to the present day, and therefore on the entire world. Yeah, on the entire world.
所以，汤姆，那是W·H·奥登，这位伟大的诗人。他在1939年1月通过BBC发表了讲话，当时他刚从中国回来，谈他在中国的第二次世界大战的经历——当然，按照传统的年代学，这场战争当时还没有开始，因为我们认为第二次世界大战始于1939年。但如果你身处东亚，事实并非如此，对吗？绝对不是。日本和中国之间的战争在1937年爆发。好吧，或者1931年。好吧，我们有机会检验这一点，但我们暂时称之为1937年。这是第二次世界大战的一种可怕的前奏，还是第二次世界大战的开端？我的意思是，这场可怕的冲突在西方鲜为人知，然而它影响深远，不仅对第二次世界大战的进程，而且当然也对从那时一直到今天的中国历史，进而对整个世界都产生了深远的影响。是的，对整个世界。
I mean, Tom, also, 14 million people died, colossal numbers of refugees, perhaps 80, 100 million refugees. I mean, this is not the weird thing is you and I were probably brought up to think of this as a sideshow, weren't we? You know, it was sort of in a 20 chapter book on the Second World War. There was one chapter called The War in the East. Yeah. But China is the first country to face a kind of Axis power onslaught. So there is really only one person to talk about this. And that is Rana Mitter, who regular listeners will remember from the absolute tour de force he gave on the Cultural Revolution a few months back. And he has written an extraordinary, brilliant, and I have to say, grueling book, because the subject is grueling. China's War with Japan, 1937 to 1945, The Struggle for Survival. And Rana,
我的意思是，汤姆，还有1400万人死亡，数量庞大的难民，大约有8000万、1亿难民。我的意思是，最奇怪的是，你和我大概从小就被灌输这样一种观念：这只是一场插曲，对吧？你知道，它有点像一本关于二战的20章图书中的一章。其中有一章叫“东方战场”。是的。但中国是第一个面对轴心国猛烈进攻的国家。所以，关于这个话题，真的只有一个人选可以交谈。那就是拉纳·米特（Rana Mitter），经常收听的听众会记得他几个月前关于文化大革命的精彩绝伦的演讲。他写了一本非凡、精彩，而且我必须说，令人筋疲力尽的书，因为这个主题本身就很折磨人。《中国的抗日战争，1937—1945：生存之争》。拉纳，
welcome back. So good to have you back. And I guess that subtitle, 1937 to 1945, you're making a statement then about when the Second World War begins, or are you? I am, Tom. It's great to be back back and Dominic, great to be back as well. And I do want to make the case in the book. In fact, I think I use the sentence at the end of the first chapter when basically the first shots are fired in a little village just outside Beijing, which is still there today. It's a place called Wanping and I've been there quite a few times. It now has a big museum of the war placed right there. But the last line of the chapter is, although nobody involved knew it, the Second World War had just begun.
欢迎回来。很高兴你能回来。我想那个副标题“1937至1945年”，你是在对第二次世界大战何时开始表态，还是说你没有？我是的，汤姆。很高兴回来，多米尼克，能回来也太棒了。我确实想在书中阐明这个观点。事实上，我想我在第一章结束时用了这样一句话：当时在北京郊外的一个小村庄里打响了第一枪，那个地方今天依然存在。那个地方叫宛平，我去过好几次。那里现在有一个大型的战争博物馆。但那一章的最后一句话是：尽管所有相关人员当时并不知道，但第二次世界大战刚刚开始。
And I think that this is the way to think about this particular theater of war. It is, of course, as it's sometimes known, the Sino-Japanese War, a war between the Chinese and Japanese. And at the beginning, Dominic gave us some of the amazing, horrifying statistics that are involved with this bloodshed that took place over these eight years. But I think it's also important to note that we have to pull the Asian war back into the idea of the global war. And we might spend a moment or two, why don't we, just working out whether or not that idea of 1937 as a start point can be logically maintained? Because this would be my argument as to why we think this should, well, I think this should be the beginning of World War II. The war, in a sense, becomes genuinely global. In 1941, you have Barbarossa, the invasion of the Soviet Union by the Nazis. You have then Pearl Harbor, of course, in December. And that's when Americans in particular, hello to any of our American listeners, you know, tend to think the war becomes global because, of course, the United States becomes involved against Japan. Until that
我认为这就是看待这个特定战区的方式。它当然就是有时被称为的中日战争，一场中国人和日本人之间的战争。在开始时，多米尼克给我们列举了一些惊人的、可怕的统计数据，这些数据与这八年里发生的流血事件有关。但我认为同样重要的是要注意，我们必须把亚洲战争重新纳入全球战争的概念中。我们也许可以花上一两分钟，为什么不呢，来探讨一下1937年作为起点的这个概念是否在逻辑上站得住脚？因为这就是我对为什么我们认为这应该——嗯，我认为这应该成为二战的起点的论证。从某种意义上说，战争真正变得全球化了。1941年，巴巴罗萨行动爆发，纳粹入侵苏联。然后当然是12月的珍珠港事件。正是在那时，尤其是美国人们——向我们所有的美国听众问好——往往认为战争变得全球化了，因为当然，美国加入了对日本的作战。在此之前
point, there's an argument that you have basically a vicious war in Europe, which is being fought by the Nazis against other major powers, the French and the British. And of course, their empires are involved. Really, it's a continental war at its heart. But if that is the beginning of World War Two, as we tend to think of 3rd of September 1939, to put W.H. Auden back into the discussion again, in that case, why not 7th of July 1937, which is when locally garrisoned Japanese troops and local Chinese troops start firing at each other in a small incident, Sarajevo, like you might say. I don't think anyone at that point knew that they were starting a continental war. And then it blows up for reasons I suspect we'll
有一种观点认为，你基本上看到的是欧洲的一场残酷战争，由纳粹与法国和英国等其他大国交战。当然，他们的帝国也卷入其中。本质上，它核心是一场大陆战争。但如果那是第二次世界大战的开始，正如我们倾向于认为的1939年9月3日——再次把W·H·奥登拉回讨论中——在这种情况下，为什么不是1937年7月7日呢？当时驻扎在当地的日本军队和中国地方部队在一个小事件中开始互相开枪，可以说是萨拉热窝式的事件。我认为当时没有人知道他们正在挑起一场大陆战争。然后，由于我猜我们会探讨的原因，它爆发了，演变成两国之间一场巨大而震撼人心的冲突，即中国和日本之间的冲突，随后它就像这场战争一样被卷入了一场全球战争，最终在1945年以灰烬和毁灭告终。这就是我支持1937年的理由。那么，拉纳，我们能把它再往前推溯得更远一点吗？因为这是一场你在书中将其根源追溯到19世纪的冲突。所以我猜，那是西方化冲击中国的冲击。西方化冲击了日本。所以日本觉得必须现代化并跟上步伐。但在中国，随着西方殖民者的种种掠夺，有一种强烈的破碎感和屈辱感等等。
explore into essentially a massive titanic conflict between two nations, between China and Japan, which then gets absorbed just like the war, into a global war that ends only with ashes and destruction in 1945. So that's my case for 1937. So Rana, can we pull it right back even further? Because this is a conflict that in your book, you trace the roots of this back to the 19th century. So the shock of westernization hitting, I guess, China. Westernization hits Japan. So Japan feels it has to modernize and keep up. But China, there's a tremendous sense of fragmentation and humiliation and so on with the sort of depredations of Western colonialists.
然后19世纪下半叶发生了这场可怕的内战，也就是我们所说的太平天国运动。所以中国在人类历史、有文字记载的历史的大部分时间里都是这样一个巨大的霸权国家，我猜，在19世纪末把它称为一个烂摊子公平吗？它不是一个烂摊子，但确实是一个非常动荡的国家。我的意思是，多米尼克，本质上我认为我们可以用来看待东亚从19世纪中期到20世纪中期这段宏大历史的一个方式是，它是两种意识形态的冲突，每一种意识形态都概括了各自国家的一些非常根本的东西。所以在亚洲大陆的中国，你看到了一种意识形态的发展，那就是中国民族主义。当时的中国在1930年代遭受了它从未真正遇到过的势力的攻击。工业化西方的力量，你知道，那是拿破仑战争结束几十年后。这是一个工业化使英国、法国和其他国家转向更强烈意识形态的时代，不仅要具备工业能力，还要建立他们自己的帝国。他们向南看，向东看——鸦片战争。换句话说，西方世界，首先是英国，然后是包括法国在内的其他人，联手基本上强行叩开了中国清朝的大门，这个自17世纪末（1644年）以来一直统治宝座的朝代。正如你所说，这个朝代在很大程度上像它之前的中国朝代一样，一直将自己视为文明的核心、世界的中心。突然之间，这些外国人，这些来自外部的人物，带着他们的大型铁甲舰来到了。野蛮人。对于“夷”这个词被翻译成“野蛮人”，我总是稍微有点戒心，尽管它是一个很好的简称。它当然包含了一种带点 amused（好笑的）轻蔑意味的东西，但我们有时会在其中加入
And then there's this horrendous civil war in the sort of second half of the 19th century, the Taiping Rebellion, as we call it. So China, which has been, for most of human history, recorded history, this tremendous sort of hegemon, I suppose, is it fair to call it a basket case in the end of the 19th century? It's not a basket case, but it's a very troubled state indeed. I mean, Dominic, essentially, I think one way we can think about that whole sweep, perhaps from the mid 19th century to the mid 20th century in East Asia is that it is a clash of two ideologies, each one of which sums up something very fundamental about each of the countries. So on the Asian mainland in China, you have the growth of one ideology, which is Chinese nationalism. China at that point is a country that in the 1830s is hit by an assault from forces that it had never really encountered before. The might of the industrialized West, you know, it's a couple of decades after the
我们自己的解释。所以我认为，这当然是不受欢迎的外国人。本质上，到了19世纪末，局势逆转了，西方工业化的力量，以及基督教和西方政治思想的兴起。当然，我之前提到过，我再次提到那个威力无比且备受追捧的商品——鸦片被引入中国，并基本上将权力的平衡从中国转向了西方。在接下来的几十年里，你基本上经历了一个时期，中国在领土和主权方面越来越多地受到外部势力的攻击，这些外部势力要么通过武力切走实实在在的肉块，香港就是一个很好的例子，要么更具生存威胁地强迫中国接受不由中国政府控制的关税，例如
Napoleonic Wars have ended. It's an era when industrialization has turned Britain, France, other countries towards this much stronger sense, not only of becoming industrially capable, but also building empires of their own. And they're looking south, they're looking east Opium Wars. In other words, the Western world, first the British, but then others, including the French, come along and basically force open the doors of China's Qing dynasty, the dynasty which had been on the throne since the late 17th century, 1644. Very much, as you said, a dynasty which, like Chinese dynasties before it, had seen itself as being at the heart of civilization, the heart of the world. And suddenly these foreigners, these figures from outside, come along with their big ironclad ships. Barbarians. I'm always slightly wary about the term Yi being translated as barbarians, though it's a good shorthand. It certainly involves a certain kind of amused contempt about it, but we sometimes put
因此，本质上，外国人提供了一个海关管理机构，这意味着中国无法控制自己的进出口关税。如果有任何人研究过当代有关英国脱欧的辩论，你或许会听到一些回响，明白为什么这至少让一些中国人气愤填膺。把它推进到20世纪，尽管所有这些紧张局势汇聚在一起，导致了中国末代皇帝、中国的小皇帝溥仪被推翻——有些人可能还记得大约30年前贝尔托卢奇的电影——五岁时就被赶下了中国的皇位，中国在1912年成为了亚洲的第一个共和国。这并没有从根本上阻止中国成为一个弱国的问题
our own interpretations on that. So certainly unwelcome foreigners, I would say. And essentially, the tables are turned in the late 19th century, the power of Western industrialization, and also the emergence of Christianity, of Western political thinking. And of course, I mentioned before, I mentioned again, that immensely powerful and highly desired good opium is brought into China and essentially turns the power relationship away from China towards the West. And for the next few decades, you basically get a period in which China is increasingly assaulted territorially and in terms of its own sovereignty by outside powers who either tear out physical chunks, Hong Kong being a good example of that, or else more existentially, force, for instance, the imposition of tariffs onto China that are not controlled by the Chinese
一个政府不稳定的国家，在这个国家里，权力要么掌握在基本上拥有这些征服权的外国列强手中，要么掌握在一群中国军阀手中——有时被称为军阀，本质上是在地区层面上拥有自己军队、总是争夺控制权的人们。这意味着到了1910年代、1920年代，你会看到许多中国民族主义者、年轻的爱国者，通常是学生，一次又一次地游行，要求中国必须振作起来。中国的精英们必须振作起来。
government. So essentially, foreigners are providing a customs authority that means that China doesn't get to control its own import and export tariffs. And if there are any people who have studied the Brexit debates in the contemporary era, you will perhaps hear some echoes of why they've got at least some Chinese very, very, very angry. And to move it on to the 20th century, although all of these tensions came together to see the overthrow of the last emperor, the boy emperor of China, Puyi, some people might remember from Bertolucci's movie from 30 or so years ago, five years old, kicked off the throne of China, and China became Asia's first republic in 1912. It didn't stop the problem, essentially, of China being a weak
当时流传的一句话是，中国遭受着来自外部的帝国主义和来自内部的军阀主义的折磨。对于其中一些年轻的民族主义者来说，答案是两位先生，正如他们所说的那样，德先生和赛先生，他们将结合起来并以某种方式最终拯救中国。然后由此涌现出了许多事物。我们无法深入探讨太多细节，中国共产主义作为一个小党派在1920年代崛起并成为了一个大党。但在那之前，真正掌握议程核心的人是中国国民党（有时被称为国府或国民党，你可能见过这个缩写）的领袖。这是一个由孙中山创立的政党，孙中山是中国的伟大民族主义领袖之一，
country that had an unstable government, in which power either lay with foreign powers who essentially have these, you know, rights of conquest, or with a group of Chinese militarists, sometimes nicknamed warlords, essentially men with armies of their own at regional level who were always vying for control. And that meant that by the 1910s, 1920s, you get a lot of Chinese nationalists, young patriots, often students, who demonstrate over and over again demanding that China has to get its act together. China's elites have to get their act together.
但他于1925年因癌症去世。他的继任者蒋介石对我们的战争故事至关重要，他字面意义上成了一个马背上的领袖，领导了一场北伐，在1928年勉强将中国重新统一在一个以南京为首都的政府之下。但在这样做的过程中，他屠杀了曾一度是他的盟友的共产党人。他调转枪口对付他们，基本上将他们视为必须被消灭的草丛中的毒蛇。这就是战争爆发前中国的状况。为了花几分钟转向日本人的视角，我刚才说过有两股意识形态力量
One of the phrases that's used at the time is that China was suffering from imperialism from outside and warlordism from inside. And for some of these young nationalists, the answer was two gentlemen, as they put it, Mr. Science and Mr. Democracy, which are going to come together and somehow eventually save China. And then lots of things emerge from that. We can't go into huge detail, but Chinese communism emerges as a small party that becomes a large party in the 1920s. But before that, the man who really takes control of the agenda is the leader of China's nationalist party, sometimes known as the Kuomintang or Kuomintang. You may have seen that abbreviation. It's a party founded by a man named Sun Yat-sen, one of the great nationalist leaders of China,
真正塑造了这一时刻。一个是那个时期崛起的中国民族主义。另一个是日本帝国主义，因为值得记住的是，世界上唯一一个拥有像英国、法国、美国那样现代帝国的国家——或者美国人不愿意承认这一点，如果你怀疑的话去问问菲律宾人——日本通过在19世纪末非常非常快地实现现代化（这一时期被称为明治维新），建立起了他们自己现代化的帝国。他们使军队、教育系统、铁路现代化，但也开始建立他们自己的帝国，以此来表明他们正坐在国际政治的高桌上。
but he died in 1925 of cancer. And his successor, Chiang Kai-shek, who will be tremendously important to our story of the war, becomes literally a man on horseback leading an expedition that very tentatively reunites China under one government in 1928 based in the capital of the city of Nanjing. But in doing so, he slaughters the communists who had temporarily been his allies. And he turns against them and basically sees them as a sort of snake in the grass who have to be wiped out. And that is the sort of position of China in the period leading up to the war. Just to flip to the Japanese side for a couple of moments, I said there were two ideological forces
到了19世纪末，亚洲的大片地区开始落入他们手中。1895年，台湾被日本人征服。1910年，朝鲜成为日本的殖民地。甚至在此之前，1904至1905年的日俄战争，尽管名义上是日俄战争，实际上却在中国领土上打响，即东北地区的满洲。其中的一些部分落入了日本人手中。然后是1931年的那场大事件，这是一个日益对抗、好战的日本帝国，此时已经放弃了民主，在这片面积相当于法德两国总和的广袤满洲领土上，基本上由日本青年军官发动了一场政变，并将其本质上
that really shaped this moment. One is that Chinese nationalism that emerges during that time. The other is Japanese imperialism, because it's worth remembering that the only country in the world that had a modern empire like the British, the French, the Americans, or the Americans don't like to admit this, just ask the Filipinos if you doubt it. The Japanese created a modernized empire of their own by basically modernizing very, very fast in the late 19th century, a period known as the Meiji Restoration. They modernized the army, education system, railways, but also started to build their own empire as a way of showing they were sitting at
变成了一个傀儡国、一个受日本控制的附庸国。而皇帝的身影又在那里出现了，对吧？如果我没记映错电影的话。完全正确。所以他们需要它，因为技术上的借口——其实有点像在我们谈论的这个时代，普京的俄罗斯在乌克兰边缘制造了所谓的自治小王国或无国籍共和国，并声称它们是得到俄罗斯支持的独立国家。同样，日本人当年征服满洲时，并没有将其设为正式殖民地。他们声称这是一个名为“满洲国”的新独立国家。为了在1932年为它找到一个傀儡元首，他们找到了被废黜的中国末代皇帝溥仪。此时的溥仪当然已经是一个年轻人，不再是个男孩了。他基本上被从北京抓走，扶上了皇位，并在极不情愿的情况下，作为满洲国的皇帝，从1932年一直统治到了1945年二战结束。顺便说一句，他后来在1966年去世，当时在北京是一个经过改造的人物。园丁，对吧？他成了一个园丁。是的，他在电影的结尾是个园丁，对吧？
the top table of international politics. And huge amounts of Asia began to fall to them by the late 19th century. 1895, Taiwan is conquered by the Japanese. 1910, Korea becomes a colony of Japan. Even before that, 1904 to 5, the Russo-Japanese War, despite the title, actually fought on Chinese territory, the northeastern territory of Manchuria. Some parts of that go over to the Japanese. And then the big one in 1931, which is an increasingly confrontational, aggressive Japanese empire that's abandoned democracy by that stage, has a coup essentially launched by Japanese junior officers in this huge territory of Manchuria, about the size of France and Germany combined, and essentially turns it
正是如此。所以，拉纳，我有三个问题。你是个如此出色的演讲者，以至于在你的……结束语过程中，我大概生出了大约50个问题。结束语。这可能是个暗号，暗示我讲得太久了。不，不，不。完全不是。完全不是。
into a puppet state, a client state under Japanese control. And that's where the emperor turns up again, isn't it? If I remember the film right. That's exactly right. So they need it because the technical case, which is a little bit actually like the way in the era we're talking about, Putin's Russia has created supposedly autonomous little kingdoms or stateless republics on the edge of Ukraine and claimed that they're independent states that are being just supported by Russia. Similarly, the Japanese, when they conquered Manchuria, didn't make it a formal colony. They claimed it was a new independent state called Manchukuo. And to find a figurehead for it in 1932, they came across the deposed last emperor of China, Pu Yi, who by now, of course, was a young man, no longer a boy. And he was essentially plucked from Beijing, put on the throne and ruled, very unhappily actually, as the emperor of Manchukuo from 1932 all the way to 1945 and the end of World War II. He eventually died, I should say, in 1966 as a sort of reformed figure in Beijing. Gardner, didn't he? He became a gardener. Yeah, he's a gardener at the end of the film, isn't he?
因为我刚才其实在想，这讲得太棒了，我甚至可以悄悄溜出房间去泡杯茶什么的。不过好吧。所以这是我的三个问题。问题一。当1931年发生事件时——也就是所谓的满洲事变或九一八事变——日本人，这其实是一次假旗行动，对吧？他们在铁轨旁引爆了一枚他们自己埋下的炸弹，然后他们说，哦，中国人正在袭击我们。哦，这下好了，我们必须立即接管满洲。完全正确。
That's right. So, Ron, I've got three questions. You're such a brilliant speaker that I've probably got about 50 questions during the course of your... Peroration. Peroration. That may be code for I'm going on too long. No, no, no. It's not at all. It's not at all.
首先，为什么中国部分地区已经有日本军队了？因为中国有一些类似于日本基地和类似的东西，对吧？所以这是为什么？所以你会经常听到一个词，它其实是一个马克思主义词汇，但由于我知道你们在《往事并不如烟》里总是很喜欢一点马克思主义，所以它被更广泛地使用了。太喜欢了。多米尼克特别喜欢。把它加进去。多米尼克肯定特别喜欢它。半殖民地这个词，在某些方面是一个相当令人不满意的词，用来描述那个时期中国的状态。除了香港等少数小地方以及威海卫等鲜为人知的地方之外，中国从未成为一个正式的殖民地。但中国的大部分领土在技术上是享有主权的。
Because I was actually thinking this is so good that I could actually just sneak out of the room and make a tea or something. But okay. So here are my three questions. Question one. When 1931 happens, so that's the so-called the Manchurian incident or the Mukden incident, the Japanese, it's a sort of false flag operation, isn't it? They have a bomb that goes off by the railway that they planted themselves and they say, oh, the Chinese are attacking us. Oh, this is, we must immediately take over Manchuria. That's exactly right.
例如，他们是国际联盟的成员，那是联合国在两次世界大战之间的前身。我能问一下关于上海的事吗？可以。那里的状况是怎样的？因为那是——那是不同寻常的吗？因为那里似乎开辟出了一种独特的欧洲领土。问得好。在这里我要厚着脸皮做个广告，那就是，总有一天，
First of all, why are there Japanese troops already in parts of China? Because there are Japanese sort of bases and things in China, aren't there? So why is that? So a phrase that you'll quite often hear, and it's actually a Marxist phrase, but it's been used more broadly speaking, because I'm sure you always love a bit of Marxism on the rest of history. Love it. Dominic loves it. Yeah. Get it in there. Dominic's particularly fond of it, I'm sure. The phrase semi-colonial, which is a rather unsatisfactory phrase in some ways that's used to describe the state of China during that time. China was never a formal colony other than some small parts like Hong Kong and also lesser known places like Weihaiwei. But the vast majority of China's territory technically was sovereign.
关于上海公共租界及其一个世纪存在的讨论，将是另一段伟大的历史故事，我相信它会做成一个精彩的播客。先在这里提一句。我们很乐意做那一期。那是个好主意。但简而言之，在1843年，就在我提到的那场鸦片战争之后——我会做成一个精彩的播客。先在这里提一句。我们很乐意做那一期。那是个好主意。但简而言之，在1843年，就在我提到的那场鸦片战争之后，1842年签署了《南京条约》。如今其中最著名的一点是香港的移交，因为随着香港
They were a member of the League of Nations, for instance, the interwar predecessor of the United Nations. Can I just ask about Shanghai? Yes. And what the state is there? Because that is, is that unusual? Because there, there does seem to be kind of distinctive European territory carved out. Great, great question. And I'm going to make a shameless plug here by saying that, you know, one of these days,
在几年前根据国家安全法被收紧控制，这现在当然成了相当热门的话题。但其中另一条条款基本上开放了五个中国港口，本质上作为一种自治的自由港，它们不在中国主权之下，或者说不完全在中国主权之下。而上海成为了其中最成功的一个。所以本质上，在很短的时间内，从1840年代开始，上海市的一个部分变成了——实际上那变成了一种由法国统治的殖民地。它被称为法租界。那更直接，是城市里面的一种小殖民地。第二个部分更大，也更复杂。
the discussion of the Shanghai International Settlement and its century of existence is one of the other great stories that I'm sure will make a wonderful podcast. Just putting that in there. We would love to do that. That is a great idea. But put very briefly, in 1843, just after that opium war that I'm sure will make a wonderful podcast. Just putting that in there. We would love to do that. That is a great idea. But put very briefly, in 1843, just after that opium war that I've mentioned, the Treaty of Nanjing is signed in 1842. The most famous aspect of that these days is the handover of Hong Kong, because that has now, of course, become quite a current issue as Hong Kong
它被称为公共租界。这是一个略具误导性的名字，因为它本质上是上海土地上的一种英国殖民地形式，但统治它的不是一个殖民总督——所以不像印度，甚至也不像香港——而是由上海工部局统治。换句话说，本质上是由纳税人组成的一个集团。所以有英国人、日本人、美国人——再次说明，我总是想把美国人的手沾进亚洲帝国的历史中，因为他们总是能逃脱自称反帝国主义的伪装，而我想确保他们正处于故事的中心。他们基本上通过征税来管理这座城市，但在20世纪之前，居住在该市那一部分的中国居民几乎没有任何权利。我能与之相比的最接近的东西大概是一个定居者社区，或许有点像罗得西亚。换句话说，
has been locked down under the national security law a couple of years ago. But one of the other clauses basically opened up five Chinese ports, essentially as sort of autonomous free ports that were not under Chinese sovereignty, or not fully under Chinese sovereignty. And Shanghai became the most successful of them. So essentially, within a short period of time, in the 1840s onwards, one section of Shanghai city became, actually that became a sort of colony, which was governed by the French. It's called the French concessions. That's more straightforward, a kind of little colony inside the city. The second part, which was larger, was more complicated.
这当然是一种殖民地局势，但城市本身是由一个主要由英国人在那个时期组成（但并非全部）的委员会管理的，而且它并不直接受伦敦殖民地办公室的控制，就像完全的殖民地那样。这其中很重要的一个原因是，你会发现英国外交部在20世纪初的备忘录中越来越感到恼火，他们基本上说他们想告诉上海的英国社区该做什么——正如历史学家罗伯特·比克斯（Robert Bickers）所写的那样，上海的英国人社区——拒绝基本上按吩咐行事，
It was called the International Settlement. That's a slightly misleading name because it's essentially a form of British colony on the soil of Shanghai, but governed not by a colonial governor, so not like India or even like Hong Kong, instead governed by the Shanghai Municipal Committee. In other words, a group of rate payers, essentially. So British, Japanese, Americans, and again, I always want to dip the blood of the Americans into the story of empire in Asia, because they always get away with claiming that they're anti-imperialists. And I want to make sure that they're right in the middle of the story. They basically raise taxes to run the city, but there are very few rights given to Chinese residents of that part of the city until into the 20th century. The nearest thing I can compare it to perhaps is a settler community, perhaps a bit like Rhodesia. In other
而只是继续做他们自己感兴趣的事。但本质上，这是一个半自治的、主要由英国人管理的城市。我对此还要进一步说明，其实这经常被遗忘。我们中的一些人只想到英国殖民地的大城市，孟买、加尔各答、比勒陀利亚、开普敦。但人们忘记了上海在很大程度上也是一座英国殖民城市。
words, it is of course a colonial situation, but the city itself is run by a committee largely of britains but not exclusively during that period and it's not directly under the control of the colonial office in the way that full colonies were one of the reasons that that matters is that the british foreign office you find more and more exasperated notes in the early 20th century basically saying that they want to tell the shanghai british community what to do the shanghai landers as the historian robert bickers has written about about them um community what to do. The Shanghailanders, as the historian Robert Bickers has written about them, refusing basically to do what they're told
如果你走到海滨，也就是著名的外滩，即使在今天，看看那些带有曼彻斯特风格的大型装饰艺术建筑，你就会发现英国对这座城市的影响至今依然是多么深远。还有汇丰银行，对吧？当然是汇丰银行。香港上海汇丰银行。
and just getting on with whatever they're actually interested in. But essentially, it's a semi-autonomous, largely British-run city. I want to further note on that, actually, it's often forgotten. Some of us think of the great cities of British colonialism, Bombay, Calcutta, Pretoria, Cape Town. But people forget that Shanghai is very much a British colonial city.
香港上海汇丰银行。虽然实际上，据我所知，在2000年代资本主义恢复之后，上海市政府现今曾向汇丰银行提出以极其敲诈勒价的高价将这栋大楼买回。但汇丰银行，我想他们意识到，事实上他们无法真正用那栋大楼来运营一家现代银行。所以那栋大楼现在我想已经是浦东发展银行，由中国人运营。而今天的汇丰银行实际上在水对面的未来主义新浦东新区。
And if you go to the waterfront, the famous Bund, even today, look at those huge Art Deco buildings that have a touch of Manchester about them as well. You will see quite how longstanding the British influence on the city remains even now. And HSBC, isn't it? HSBC, of course. The Hong Kong and Shanghai Bank.
如果你走进旧的香港上海银行大楼（在正常时期，也就是非大流行之类的时候，游客是被允许进去的），然后抬头看，你会看到这幅奇妙的壁画，上面画着香港上海银行曾运营业务的八大城市，显然有香港和上海，还有曼谷以及当时帝国的其他城市。画得非常漂亮，是一幅非常非常有趣的壁画。如果你去不了上海，而你目前大概也去不了，你实际上可以在互联网上找到那个图像。非常值得一看。所以拉纳，把你带回日本人那里，日本人是基本上拥有一个小小落脚点的列强之一，对吧？他们在满洲有这条铁路，但他们在全中国也到处都有兵营之类的地方。所以我的问题是，为什么他们还不满足？换句话说，为什么会有这种
The Hong Kong and Shanghai Bank. Although actually, I believe the story is that after, you know, when things got back to capitalism back in the 2000s, the city council of Shanghai in the present day offered HSBC the building back for some incredibly extortionate price. But HSBC, I think, realised that in fact, they couldn't really run a modern bank out of that building. So that building is, I think, now the Pudong Development Bank run by the Chinese. And today's HSBC is actually across the water in the futuristic New Pudong District.
内部的活力、这种躁动，促使日本人在1930年代甚至想要在军事上卷入中国？是什么在推动这一切？主要的推动力，虽然有很多，但要说到主要的推动力，那是情感上的。日本是唯一一个从1850年代差点面临被西方列强殖民危险的国家，在半个世纪后转变为一个独立的殖民列强的非欧洲国家，它取得了令人震惊的迅速崛起，他们看到在1920和30年代，正如你们所知，西方帝国趋于安定——我的意思是，已经存在的殖民地并没有被归还，但同时也有这样一种感觉，即英国和法国的殖民地当时不应该扩张，其中一些应该变成国际联盟委任统治地，换个名字的殖民地，
But if you go into the old Hong Kong Shanghai Bank building, which in normal times, non-pandemic and so forth, tourists are allowed to do. And then look up, you will see this fantastic mural with pictures of the eight great cities that the Hong Kong Shanghai Bank operated in, obviously Hong Kong and Shanghai, but also Bangkok and other cities of empire of that time. Beautifully painted and a really, really interesting mural. And if you can't get to Shanghai, which you probably can't at the moment, you can find that image on the internet, actually. It's well worth looking at. So Ron, to take you back to the Japanese, the Japanese are one of the powers, aren't they, that have basically got a little toehold. And they have this railway in Manchuria, but they also have barracks all over China and things. So my question is, why aren't they happy with that? So in other words, why is there this
你可能会这么说，但尽管如此。日本人非常明确且经常地说，看，这不公平。我们很晚才加入帝国这场游戏。凭什么英国人和法国人在非洲和亚洲拥有这大片领土却可以保留，而当我们想做类似的事情时，人们却说不再允许了。所以我认为这种情绪占很大一部分。第二部分我认为与此相关，但可能略有不同，是由大萧条推动的。本质上，在1920年代末，当世界在大萧条和华尔街股灾之后转向经济自给自足时，日本发现自己被越来越多地排挤在国际市场之外。我有时喜欢说，这是我的另一句小名言，如果你愿意的话可以拿去剖析。第二次世界大战部分是由美国妇女的丝袜引发的，因为20世纪初日本工业实力的很大一部分在于轻工业纺织品。换句话说，年轻女性——通常是年轻女性——在日本工厂的恶劣条件下工作，吸入所有纤维导致肺病，制造棉织品和丝绸产品，包括丝袜。而在1920年代，当斯穆特-霍利关税法和其他关税阻止了日本以及实际上大多数外国商品出口
internal dynamism, this restlessness, that means the Japanese even want to get involved in China militarily in the 1930s? What is driving all that? The primary driver, and there are a lot of them, but to go to the primary driver is emotional. Japan was the only non-European nation to have made this astonishingly rapid rise from being a country that was nearly in danger of being colonized itself by western powers in the 1850s to being a colonial power in its own right half a century later and they looked at the way that by the 1920s and 30s as you know western empires tended to be settled i mean the colonies that existed weren't being given back but there was also a feeling that british uh colonies and french colonies shouldn't expand at that time and some of them should be turned into League of Nations mandates, colonies by another name,
进入美国，这类商品市场的崩溃意味着中国的——抱歉，日本的乡村经济非常非常快地被摧毁了。所有的这些农村青年男女突然发现自己基本上没有了出口市场。当然，这助长了一种愤怒的政治，向政客们质问：你们打算怎么解决这个问题？而答案在某些情况下往往是，我们在我们的地区利益范围内扩张。特别是，这意味着中国大陆。
you might say, but nonetheless. And the Japanese quite explicitly said quite often, well, look, this isn't fair. We came along late to the game of empire. Why on earth should the British and French get to keep this huge swathe of territory they have around the world in Africa and Asia? But when we want to do something similar, people say it's no longer permitted. So that emotion, I think, is a large part of it. The second part that I think links to that, but it's perhaps slightly separate, is pushed by the Great Depression. Essentially, in the late 1920s, when the world turns to economic autarky in the aftermath of the Depression and the Wall Street crash, Japan found itself being increasingly shut out of international markets. I sometimes like to say, here's another one of my little phrases, you're welcome to pick
这就是为什么你会驻扎这些军队的原因。本质上，日本利用其军事优势来证明它享有特权。再次，你可能在这里又听到了普京在俄罗斯和乌克兰的回响，在它附近的地理区域内享有特权，还有什么地方能比中国更近呢？并本质上利用中国国内政治的软弱性，迫使中国统治者签署协议，允许日本军队驻扎在中国领土上，表面上是为了保护日本的利益。再次重申，不断回到与普京的比较。如果日本平民发现自己受到侮辱、伤害或伤害，那么日本军队就被允许基本上
apart if you like. World War II was started in part by American women's silk stockings, because a large part of Japan's industrial strength in the early 20th century was in light industrial textiles. In other words, young women, quite often it was young women, working in Japanese factories in horrible conditions, getting lung diseases from all the fibers, making cotton and silk products, including stockings. And in the 1920s, when the Smoot-Hawley and other terrorists prevented exports of Japanese and indeed most foreign goods
前来拯救他们。正如你所想象的那样，发生了不止一起事件，日本平民发现自己受到不好的对待，其中可能带有挑衅成分，这使得日本的军事存在得以进一步扩大。所以这本质上意味着，日本在中国建立的非正式帝国在1920和30年代变得非常庞大，而且坦率地说，到那个阶段已经不那么非正式了。但是兰登（拉纳），我可不可以——为了把镜头彻底拉远，中国和日本之间的关系，我的意思是，这是一个非常长的历史，很明显，他们在地理上非常接近。历史上，日本深受中国的影响。对于日本作为其自身文化的发源地和这个极其古老的文明，日本人对中国是否仍然有一种自卑情结？还是他们已经完全压抑了这一点？他们现在是否带着轻蔑来看待中国人？在19世纪末到20世纪初之间，中国和日本之间经历了一次真正的感情再平衡。
coming into the United States, the collapse in market for these sorts of goods meant that China, sorry, Japan's rural economy was destroyed, you know, very, very quickly. And all of these rural young women and men suddenly found themselves essentially without an export market. And that fueled, of course, an angry politics, which said, well, what are you going to do about it to the politicians? And the answer tended in some cases to say, well, we expand in our areas of regional interest. In particular, that means the mainland of China.
它有两个部分，几乎是相对立的。用中国话来说，可以说是阴和阳。一方面，这是不可否认的。但到了20世纪初，日本在区域和全球政治中已经成为了更强大的行动者。因为它的工业化更成功。它的工业化更成功。它更富有，并且能够行使自己的意志。
So that's the reason why you get the reason that you get these troops being stationed. Essentially, Japan used its military superiority to make the case that it had special rights. Again, you may be hearing echoes of Putin in Russia and Ukraine here again, special rights in geographical areas that were close to it and where could be closer than China, and essentially use the weakness of China's internal politics to force Chinese rulers to sign agreements that Japanese troops could be stationed on Chinese territory, ostensibly to protect Japanese interests. And again, keep coming back to the Putin comparison. If Japanese civilians found themselves being insulted or injured or hurt, then Japanese troops were allowed to basically
因此，当时中国的许多精英中产生了一种强烈的感觉。天哪，我们必须向日本学习，因为他们显然已经弄清楚了如何击退外国人并让自己变得强大。许多中国精英的这种感觉，比如梁启超——19世纪末中国的伟大知识分子之一，最终也去了日本的人，所以他感到了一种亲近感——他们花了很多时间实际去研究，为什么日本成功了
come and save them. And as you can imagine, there was more than one incident in which Japanese civilians found themselves being treated badly, possibly with an element of provocation, which allowed that Japanese military presence to expand even further. So that essentially meant the informal empire that Japan had in China became very extensive by the 1920s and 30s, and frankly, wasn't all that informal by that stage. But Brandon, can I just, just to pull the camera right back, the relationship between China and Japan, I mean, it's very, it's a very long one, obviously, they're very geographically close. Historically, Japan had been hugely influenced by China. Is there any sense still of an inferiority complex that the Japanese have towards China as the kind of birthplace of its own culture and this immensely ancient civilization? Or have they completely suppressed that? Do they now regard the Chinese with contempt? There's a real emotional rebalancing that goes on between China and Japan between the late 19th and early 20th century.
而我们失败了。在日本方面，我认为有一种复杂的情感，因为你提到的悠久的中国文化传统——儒家传统、将文言文作为语言工具的传统——是如此悠久，以至于无法一朝一夕被彻底推翻。因此，既有一种几乎是怨恨老大步履蹒跚、又觉得要把老小引入现代性的混合情感。值得一提的是，我认为在仇恨的故事中，这一点有时会被掩盖——这种仇恨在那个时期及随后许多中国人和日本人之间变得非常真实——也就是说，尽管有帝国（这里实际上与英法帝国也有相似之处），
And it has two parts which sit almost in opposition to each other. Yin and yang, you might say, to use a Chinese phrase. On the one hand, it was undeniable. But by the early 20th century, Japan was the more powerful actor in regional and in global politics. Because it's industrialized more successfully. It industrialized more successfully. It's richer and it was able to exercise its will.
尽管日本对中国的征服引发了愤怒，但也存在着一定程度的文化互动，并且在文化阵营中，相对于军事阵营而言，实际上有一种更具平等主义的感觉。因此，许多中国年轻人拿着日本奖学金到东京和中国学习。虽然他们多少有些怨恨这些奖学金可能伴随着的那种相当居高临下的施舍，但能够来到东京这样一个大都市中心的机会——韩国人会来，东南亚人会来，中国人和日本人都会来——被视为一种文化大熔炉，它实际上承认了中国、日本
And therefore, there was a strong sense amongst many of China's elites at that time. My gosh, we have to learn from Japan because they've obviously worked out how to push back the foreigners and actually become strong themselves. And that sense of many Chinese elites, people like Liang Qichao, one of the great intellectuals of late 19th century China and a figure who eventually actually went to Japan in the end. So he felt something of an affinity. They spent a lot of time actually working out why on earth has Japan succeeded
以及其他东亚人之间存在着大量共享文化的事实。所以双方的心情相当矛盾。但毫无疑问，总体而言，随着日本人走向大亚洲主义的概念——把自己视为一个必须向其他亚洲同胞指明方向的头等亚洲强国——他们绝对把自己置于了一种俯视其他亚洲国家的境地。毫无疑问。拉纳，在我们继续推进到1937年之前，还有最后一个问题。多米尼克，你的两个问题已经问过了吗？
and we have failed. On the Japanese side, I think there was a sort of ambiguity of feeling because the long Chinese cultural tradition that you've mentioned, the Confucian tradition, tradition of using classical Chinese as a linguistic tool, was so longstanding that it couldn't simply be overthrown at one blow. And therefore, the mixture of feelings of both kind of almost resentment that the elder brother had fallen backwards and that the younger brother had to be sort of brought into modernity was found there. It's worth saying one of the things, I think this sometimes gets a bit lost in the story of the hatred, which became very real between many Chinese and many Japanese during that time and subsequently, which is that despite empire, and there are parallels here actually with the British and the French empires too,
而我们失败了。在日本方面，我认为有一种情感上的模棱两可，因为你提到的那种长期存在的中国文化传统，即儒家传统、将文言文作为语言工具的传统，是如此源远流长，以至于无法一朝一夕就被彻底推翻。因此，那种认为“老大哥”已经倒退，而“小弟”不得不被带入现代性的复合情感便油然而生。值得一提的是，我认为这在那种仇恨的故事中有时会被忽视，这种仇恨在当时以及随后许多中国人和日本人之间变得非常真实，也就是说，尽管存在帝国主义——这里实际上与英法帝国有相似之处——
despite the anger that came from Japanese conquest in China, there was also a certain amount of cultural interaction and actually a feeling of more egalitarianism on the cultural front as opposed to necessarily the military front. So a lot of young Chinese came on Japanese scholarships to study in Tokyo and in China. And while they somewhat resented, you know, the kind of rather condescending charity that might be associated with these scholarships, the opportunity to actually come to a metropolitan center, which Tokyo was, you know, where Koreans would come, where Southeast Asians would come, where Chinese would come, as well as Japanese, was regarded as a sort of cultural melting pot that actually acknowledged the fact that there was a lot of shared culture between China, Japan,
尽管日本对中国的征服引发了愤怒，但在文化层面上也存在一定程度的文化互动，并且实际上在文化战线上有一种比军事战线上更多的平等主义感觉。因此，许多中国青年依靠日本的奖学金来到东京和中国学习。虽然他们对这些奖学金可能伴随的某种相当居高临下的施舍感到有些不满，但能够来到东京这样一个大都市中心的机会——韩国人、东南亚人、中国人都曾来到这里，日本人也是如此——被视为一种文化大熔炉，它实际上承认了中国、日本之间存在着大量共享文化的事实，
and other East Asians as well. So it's quite an ambivalent set of feelings on both sides. But there's no doubt that overall, the Japanese, as they move towards this idea of pan-Asianism, of themselves as a sort of first-class Asian power who has to show the other Asian powers the way, that they definitely got themselves into a position where they were looking to lord it over the other Asian nations. There's little doubt about that. Rana, one more question before we move on towards 1937. Dominic, have you had your two questions already?
以及其他东亚国家也是如此。因此，双方都存在一种相当矛盾的情感。但毫无疑问，总体而言，随着日本人走向这种泛亚洲主义的理念，将自己视为一个必须为其他亚洲国家指明道路的“一流亚洲国家”，他们无疑陷入了一种试图对其他亚洲国家颐指气使的境地。毫无疑问。拉娜，在我们转向1937年之前，还有一个问题。多米尼克，你的两个问题已经问过了吗？
No, this is my final question, Tom. This is my third question. So I've been very good at keeping my questions kind of hanging. So Rana uh why isn't 1931 the beginning of the second world war because that's the moment when you have this false flag operation and the japanese as you said they can't they basically conquer an area the size of france and germany put together in manchuria and they set up their puppet state and that's a from the sort of perspective of the league of nations and sort of western opinion that's seen as a sort of flagrant act of aggression and annexation. So why isn't that the beginning? Why isn't that the turning point? Well, first of all, Dominic, if you go to China and say what I've just said, which is that it starts, I think, in 1937 properly, you can get into big trouble these days.
不，这是我的最后一个问题，汤姆。这是我的第三个问题。我一直很擅长让我的问题悬而未决。所以拉纳，呃，为什么1931年不是第二次世界大战的开始呢？因为那是你有了这个虚假旗帜行动（自导自演）的时刻，正如你所说，日本人，他们基本上征服了满洲的一个面积相当于法国和德国加起来的地区，他们建立了他们的傀儡政权，从国际联盟以及西方舆论的某种角度来看，这被视为一种公然的侵略和兼并行为。那么，为什么那不是开始呢？为什么那不是转折点？嗯，首先，多米尼克，如果你去中国，说出我刚刚说过的话——即我认为它真正开始于1937年，你现在可能会惹上大麻烦。
So a little bit of political subversion right here on the podcast, you know, send it over to Beijing now and let's get the handcuffs out. Because about four years ago, it was actually legally decreed in China that the official start of World War II is 1931 because of the Manchurian incident. And that's now an officially maintained position. So for instance, books in China have had textbooks have had to be changed to reflect that. Prior to that, there was a very lively debate in the Chinese academic world, and that still actually does, you know, exist, I think, although not so officially now, about whether it was 1931 or 1937. Just to add to the mix, actually, for a very long time, certainly during the Cold War years, the Japanese, particularly the Japanese left,
所以，这就在播客里进行了一点政治颠覆，你知道，现在把它发到北京去，把手铐拿出来吧。因为大约四年前，中国实际上通过法律正式规定，由于满洲事变，第二次世界大战的官方开始时间是1931年。而这现在是一个官方坚持的立场。因此，例如，中国的图书、教科书不得不进行修改以反映这一点。在此之前，中国学术界曾进行过非常热烈的辩论，而且实际上这种辩论现在仍然存在，我认为，尽管现在没有那么官方了，即到底是1931年还是1937年。为了让情况更复杂一点，事实上，在很长一段时间里，当然是在冷战期间，日本人，尤其是日本左翼，
have referred to this whole period, I always think slightly mysteriously, as Jugo Nen no Senso, the 15-year war. I'm not quite sure how 1931 to 45 counts as 15 unless you sort of actually count the fullness of each particular year. But you know, never mind that. The point is that the Japanese have also seen this as a long period in which there is a continuity. However, here are the reasons briefly that I think that 1937 is the starting point. First of all, during the war itself, and for many, many decades afterwards, the Chinese who were fighting it thought it had begun in 1937. So at the end of 1945, when the war was over, all Chinese newspapers, commentators,
一直把这段时期称为“十五年战争”（Jugo Nen no Senso），我总是觉得这个说法有点神秘。我不太确定从1931年到1945年怎么算成15年，除非你把每个特定年份的完整时间都算进去。但你知道，别管那个了。重点是，日本人也一直把这看作是一个具有连续性的漫长时期。然而，简而言之，我认为1937年是起点的理由如下。首先，在战争期间以及之后的很多很多年里，参与作战的中国人都认为战争始于1937年。因此，在1945年底战争结束时，中国的所有报纸、评论员、
you know, journalists, writers, historians, talked about the great eight-year war of resistance against Japan that they had fought, Ban Yan Kang Zhang in Chinese. Nobody at that point talked about, or very few people, I should think, talked about it being a 14-year war. So, in that sense, I would give the contemporary survivors of the war a certain amount of leeway. But leaving that aside, there are analytical reasons, I think, as well. And I'll just go for one. If you look at what happens after 1931 and this conquest and annexation of Manchuria into a client state of Japan, it's not a straight downhill path from there all the way to the outbreak of war in 1937.
你知道，记者、作家、历史学家，都在谈论他们所经历的伟大的八年抗日战争，中文里叫“八年抗战”。当时没有人——或者我想极少数人——认为这是一场十四年的战争。所以，从这个意义上说，我会给战争的当代幸存者以一定的宽容。但抛开这一点不谈，我认为也有分析上的理由。我只举一个。如果你看看1931年之后发生的事情，以及满洲被征服并吞并为日本的附属国，从那时起一直到1937年战争爆发，并不是一条一路直下的平坦道路。
In 1933, Chiang Kai-shek's nationalist government and the Japanese government at the time undertake an uneasy truce. It's called the Truce of Tangu. And it's basically the beginning of a two-year period when both sides, I think the Chinese more sincerely than the Japanese, to be honest, are trying to reach a new status quo. Again, I'm going to keep reaching for these Putin-type analogies here, but they do seem in so many ways so powerful. So do you think the Ukraine war began in 2014 with Crimea or this February 2022? You don't necessarily have to answer the question, but you see the distinction I'm making there. Lots of people actually now talking about the reinvasion of Ukraine. And you could talk about the restarting of the war in China. But overall,
1933年，蒋介石的国民政府与当时的日本政府达成了一项勉强的休战协议。这被称为《塘沽协定》。这基本上是一个为期两年的时期的开始，在此期间，双方——老实说，我认为中国比日本更真诚——都在试图达成一个新的现状。再次说明，我在这里还是要搬出普京式的类比，但它们在很多方面似乎都非常有说服力。那么，你认为乌克兰战争是从2014年的克里米亚开始的，还是从2022年2月开始的？你不一定非要回答这个问题，但你能看出我在这里所做的区别。现在实际上有很多人在谈论乌克兰的再次入侵。你也可以谈论中国战争的重启。但总体而言，
there was a status quo, a very uneasy status quo achieved certainly by 1933 in Manchuria, and the flare up didn't happen again until 1937. So I might leave you with the way in which Chinese historians today try and square the circle of this distinction. Nowadays, the official position, if you kind of want to say that you think it's really 1937, but you don't want to say it, well, you're not able to say it publicly because it's no longer permitted in textbooks and so forth, is to say that 1931 is the beginning of the overall war of resistance in the Chinese phrase. And then 1937 is the beginning of the full scale war of resistance. And that is a way, I think, of trying to get both of those viewpoints in. But that's why I personally would still stick to 1937 and argue for that as
到1933年，满洲确实实现了某种现状，一种非常勉强的现状，而冲突直到1937年才再次爆发。所以我可能会留给你们思考今天中国历史学家是如何试图圆这个区别之局的。如今，如果你想说你认为真正的起点是1937年，但又不想说出来——好吧，你不能公开说，因为教科书等已经不再允许这样说了，官方的立场是：用中文的说法，1931年是整个抗日战争的开始，而1937年是全面抗战的开始。我认为，这是一种试图将这两种观点都容纳进来的方式。但这就是为什么我个人仍然坚持1937年，并将其论证为
the beginning of, well, as we've said, the Second World War in Asia, but also actually globally. Okay. Well, I think we should take a break here. And then when we come back, let's look at the start of the outbreak of the full-scale war of resistance, and we'll move to 1937. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And And we'll move to 1937. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news,
——正如我们所说——亚洲第二次世界大战的开始，而且实际上也是全球大战的开始。好吧。我想我们应该在这里休息一下。当我们回来时，让我们来看看全面抗战爆发的起点，我们将进入1937年。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。而我们共同主持《娱乐至死》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周必看的娱乐新闻，
reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Hello, welcome back to The Rest Is History.
评论，以及一抹娱乐圈八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外节目和提前获得现场门票的福利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。大家好，欢迎回到《历史余音》（The Rest Is History）。
We are looking at what Rana Mehta is, our guest, is casting as the outbreak of the Second World War. And Rana, we have got to 1937. But before the war actually begins, you've been talking about Chiang Kai-shek, the Chinese leader, leader of the nationalists. But there are two other figures who over the course of the war will play very, very significant roles. One of them, very, very famous name, we've already devoted an entire episode to him, Mao Zedong, communist. But the other one, Wang Jingwei, who you describe as a man of extraordinary good looks in your book. What is there to say about Wang Jingwei, other than his extraordinary good looks, that means that he's such a kind of key figure in this story? Albeit one that, you know, compared to Mao and
我们正在探讨我们的嘉宾拉纳·米特（Rana Mitter）将什么界定为第二次世界大战的爆发。拉纳，我们已经讲到了1937年。但在战争真正开始之前，你一直在谈论中国领导人、国民党领袖蒋介石。但在战争进程中将扮演非常非常重要角色的还有另外两个人物。其中一位是个非常非常著名的名字，我们已经专门为他做了一整期节目——毛泽东，共产党人。但另一位是汪精卫，你在书中将他描述为一个拥有非凡美貌的男子。除了他非凡的美貌之外，关于汪精卫还有什么要说的，能说明他是这个故事中的一个如此关键的人物呢？尽管与毛泽东和
Chiang Kai-shek, much less well known. Well, I should say that Wang Jingwei's good looks are not incidental to this man's history, and I'll explain why in a moment. Wang Jingwei was one of the most prominent revolutionaries against the last Chinese dynasty, the Qing dynasty that was overthrown in 1911, 1912. He was an extremely fierce opponent of the Manchu Qing dynasty that ruled China at that time. You can think, you know, in the same way that one thinks of the sort of late 19th century Russian revolutionaries who overthrew the Tsars, you know, they assassinated Alexander III. They weren't immediately successful. There's a lot of persecution, but eventually the Russian revolution overthrew the Bolsheviks as well.
蒋介石相比，他远没有那么知名。嗯，我应该说，汪精卫的美貌与这个男人的历史并不是偶然相关的，我等一下会解释原因。汪精卫是推翻中国最后一个朝代——在1911、1912年被推翻的清朝——的最著名的革命者之一。他是当时统治中国的满清王朝极其激烈的反对者。你可以这样想，就像人们看待19世纪末推翻沙皇的俄国革命者一样，你知道，他们暗杀了亚历山大二世。他们并没有立即成功。有大量的迫害，但最终俄国革命也推翻了布尔什维克。
So Wang Jingwei was very much in that mode of an anti-monarchist, an anti-royalist who was seeking to overthrow the last Chinese dynasty. And his raven-haired beauty was something that was very, very widely noted amongst those people who hung out in revolutionary circles and beyond. It was said that when he was caught, because he took a leaf out of the Russian book and
因此，汪精卫非常符合那种反君主制、反保皇派的模式，他试图推翻中国的最后一个朝代。他那乌黑的头发和美貌在那些在革命圈子及其他地方混迹的人当中非常非常广为人知。据说，当他被捕时——因为他效仿俄国人的做法，
chucked a bomb at a prince of the Qing royal house, he didn't miss, but it didn't kill him. But he was, of course, nabbed and sentenced to death. And it is said, certainly, that one of the reasons that his sentence was commuted from death to long term imprisonment was that one of the court ladies, the Manchu court, caught sight of him and said, you know, this young man is so good looking, we can't possibly cut his head off. So if that is true, then his chiseled good looks, feel free to put his name into a search engine if you want to see what they look like. Plenty of pictures of him certainly made a difference. But his political significance, for good or ill, doesn't really, in the end, lie on the shoulders of his looks. The best way to think about Wang Jingwei, I think, is as a figure who in some ways is parallel to figures who may be better known to listeners who know the European World War II story, such as
向清朝皇室的一位亲王扔了一枚炸弹，他没有失手，但没能炸死对方。当然，他被捕并被判处死刑。据说，他的刑期从死刑减为长期监禁的原因之一，确实是清廷的一位宫女瞥见了他，然后说，你知道，这个年轻人长得太好看了，我们绝不能砍他的头。所以，如果这是真的，那么他雕刻般的美貌——如果你想看看他长什么样，大可以在搜索引擎里输入他的名字——大量的照片确实发挥了作用。但他的政治意义，不论好坏，最终其实并不建立在他的外表之上。我认为，理解汪精卫最好的方式是，他某种程度上类似于那些对了解欧洲二战故事的听众来说可能更熟悉的人物，比如
Laval or Pétain in France or Quisling in Norway. In other words, collaborators with the invaders. And Wang Jingwei is probably the most famous, certainly the most well-known and notorious of those who collaborated with the Japanese during their occupation of China. In the 1920s and 30s, Wang Jingwei became one of the most prominent figures in the nationalist revolution of the time. He was second really in prominence only to Chiang Kai-shek, who became the leader of China once he'd set up his regime at Nanjing in 1928. And Wang Jingwei had a very difficult relationship with him. The two of them never trusted each other an inch. But through much of the 1930s, Wang Jingwei became a very prominent figure in the cabinets of China at that time. He was essentially prime minister at
法国的拉瓦尔（Laval）或贝当（Pétain），或是挪威的吉斯林（Quisling）。换句话说，就是与侵略者合作的合作者。汪精卫可能是那些在日本占领中国期间与之合作的人中最著名、也最臭名昭著的一个。在20世纪20和30年代，汪精卫成为了当时国民革命中最著名的人物之一。1928年在南京建立政权后，他的名望实际上仅次于蒋介石。汪精卫与他的关系非常艰难。两人从未信任过对方哪怕一英寸。但在20世纪30年代的大部分时间里，汪精卫成为了当时中国内阁中非常显赫的人物。他甚至曾一度担任过总理。
one point. And he became known as a figure who probably was more sympathetic to the idea of a deal with Japan during the 1930s after the Manchurian incident than some of the other more sort of hardline nationalists in the government. But at that point, there was no doubt that he was regarded as a figure of the highest significance in the Chinese government alongside Chiang Kai-shek and other nationalist figures. So a very prominent national level figure who everyone would have known, rather like a figure like Pierre Laval in France at exactly the same time, the Third Republic. So we'll come back to his story a little bit later. But Rana, you talked about Chiang Kai-shek. And I guess it's easy to have the impression that Chiang Kai-shek is leading a united, coherent China. But am I right in thinking that in that period,
并且，在满洲事变之后的30年代，与政府中其他一些更强硬的民族主义者相比，他以对与日本达成交易的想法可能更具同情心而闻名。但当时，毫无疑问，他被视为中国政府中与蒋介石和其他国民党人物并列的最高级别的人物。因此，这是一个每个人都会知道的非常显赫的国家级人物，就像完全同一时期的法国第三共和国的皮埃尔·拉瓦尔（Pierre Laval）一样。所以我们稍后会再回到他的故事。但是拉纳，你谈到了蒋介石。我想人们很容易留下这样的印象，即蒋介石领导着一个统一、连贯的中国。但是，如果我认为在那段时期——
coming up to 1937, the warlordism, as it were, is not quite as bad as it was. But China is still pretty divided, isn't it? So you have Chiang Kai-shek and the nationalists. You also have Mao and the communists who've done their long march. So they've kind of gone into the countryside and formed an alternative power base, I suppose. So is that one reason why the Japanese think, well, this place is really fragmented and divided, we can just waltz in and take it all? One phrase that was used by a Japanese commentator, admittedly one who had a vested interest in trying to split China up, was that China at that time, the 1930s, was not a country, it was a geographical expression. Now, I think that's too strong. But the way in which I try
临近1937年，军阀割据虽然没有以前那么严重，但中国仍然相当分裂，我的想法对吗？所以你有蒋介石和国民党。你还有毛泽东和完成了长征的共产党人。所以他们算是进入了农村，建立了一个替代权力基础，我想。那么，这是否是日本人认为“这个地方真的很破碎很分裂，我们可以直接大摇大摆进去夺取一切”的一个原因呢？有个日本评论员曾用过一个词——诚然，这个人有着试图分裂中国的既得利益——那就是当时的中国，即30年代的中国，不是一个国家，而是一个地理上的概念。现在，我认为这话说得太重了。但我试图
and explain perhaps the view from Nanjing, Chiang Kai-shek's capital, and how it looked if you were sitting in his presidential palace, still there, by the way, in the in the center from Nanjing, Chiang Kai-shek's capital, and how it looked if you were sitting in his presidential palace, still there, by the way, in the center of Nanjing, you might think of it as a sort of nerve center in which the further you get away from Nanjing, the less power the national government of China has. So if you think about the area, which is actually some of the most prosperous and some of the most culturally significant part of China in the kind of Yangtze Delta area, that's some east central China, you might say. So if you know big cities like Shanghai, Nanjing, provinces like Zhejiang, Jiangsu, those would all be basically part of that heartland. That's really where the Nationalist Revolution had its strongest area of control, along with Guangdong, Canton or Guangzhou, down in the south of China, where it had another beachhead, you might say. And those areas meant that a combination of local elites,
解释南京（蒋介石的首都）的视角的方式，以及如果你坐在他的总统府里——顺便说一下，它现在仍然在南京市中心——你可能会把它想象成一个神经中枢：你距离南京越远，中国国家政府的权力就越小。所以如果你想想这个地区——实际上它是长江三角洲地区中国最繁荣、文化上最重要的部分之一，你也可以说它是中国的中东部。所以如果你知道大城市如上海、南京，各省如浙江、江苏，这些基本上都是那个核心区的一部分。这确实是国民革命控制力最强的地区，还有南方的广东、省城广州，在那里它可以说是有了另一个滩头阵地。这些地区意味着，当地精英、
business people, rural landowners, and so forth, who were pretty dedicated to the Nationalist cause, meant that the government was reasonably stable, even though it had various things that were very problematic. For instance, it didn't have a very, very strong regular tax income. And a lot of that was dependent on an institution called the Maritime Customs Service, which essentially was, again, as many things were at this time, was run by a bunch of Brits. It was actually founded by an Ulsterman called Sir Robert Hart, who had come from Portadown and ended up in the service of China. But even though he died in 1911, the customs remained as a sort of reliable stream of income for the recognized Chinese government. But the further you got away from Nanjing, the further you find yourself into
商界人士、农村地主等的结合，他们相当忠于国民党事业，这意味着政府相当稳定，尽管它存在各种非常具挑战性的问题。例如，它没有非常非常强大的常规税收收入。其中很大一部分依赖于一个叫做“海关总税务司”（Maritime Customs Service）的机构，而这个机构基本上——和当时很多事情一样——是由一群英国人管理的。它实际上是由一个来自波塔当（Portadown）的阿尔斯特人罗伯特·哈特（Sir Robert Hart）爵士创立的，他来到中国并最终为中国服务。但尽管他在1911年去世，海关仍然作为被承认的中国政府的一种可靠的收入来源保留了下来。然而，你离南京越远，你就会发现自己身处
areas where essentially other Chinese military leaders might pay nominal allegiance to Chiang Kai-shek's nationalist government, but in practice, did whatever the heck they wanted. So Sichuan down in the southwest, Manchuria before the Japanese conquest, Dongbei, the northeast, which was under the control of a younger warlord called the Young Marshal, or indeed large parts of northeast central China, Shanxi province, ruled by an extremely, in some ways quite progressive warlord, Yan Xishan, very much against things like foot binding, but a man who kept his own army very, very close to hand to make sure that Chiang Kai-shek or any other ruler couldn't simply tell him what to do. So Chiang Kai-shek was doing a combination of bribery, coercion and conquest out that one of the many reasons why China became destabilized in the war years was that they had to flee that cultural heartland in Nanjing and around and instead make their way to another part of China, the southwest, that is the center of gravity, cultural, economic, financial. And would it be fair to say that you've got Beijing in the north, although it's called
这样一些地区：基本上其他中国军事领袖可能对蒋介石的国民党政府效忠只是名义上的，但实际上随心所欲，想干什么就干什么。比如西南部的四川，日本征服之前的满洲（东北），由一个被称为“少帅”的年轻军阀控制；或者东北中部的大部分地区，山西省，由一个在某些方面相当进步的军阀阎锡山统治，他非常反对诸如缠足之类的事情，但他把自己的军队紧紧抓在手里，以确保蒋介石或其他任何统治者都不能简单地对他的命令言听计从。因此，蒋介石一直在采用收买、胁迫和征服相结合的手段……中国在战争年代变得不稳定的众多原因之一，就是他们不得不逃离南京及周边的文化核心区，转而前往中国的另一个地区——西南部，即文化、经济、金融的重心。说北京在北方——虽然它当时叫
what, Beiping? Beiping, Northern Peace, because Nanjing had become the capital. And so Beijing, which means northern capital, could not use that name at that time. So that was a former imperial capital. Then you have Nanjing that we've been talking about, which is the nationalist capital. Again, a kind of very ancient Chinese city. So kind of very important in the Chinese psyche. And then you have Shanghai, which is the great kind of commercial port and center. So you have these three ports. You have Chiang Kai-shek head of the nationalist government you've explained you have all these warlords as well you have the communists who at this point are what I mean how how much of a a power are they they are they're kind of sent north central
什么？北平？北平，意为北方的和平，因为南京已经成为了首都。因此，意为“北方首都”的北京，在当时是不能使用那个名字的。所以那是前帝国首都。然后是你一直在谈论的南京，它是国民政府的首都。同样，这是一个非常古老的中国城市。因此在中国的精神世界中非常重要。然后你有上海，它是伟大的商业港口和中心。所以你有这三个港口。你有正如你所解释的国民政府最高领导人蒋介石，你还有所有这些军阀，你还有此时此地的共产党人——他们算是什么？我的意思是，他们的势力有多大？他们某种程度上被派往中北
northern China central northern China Shanxi province basically as you'll have discussed on another episode I know of um of the podcast of the rest is history. They have been sent on the Long March that takes place in 1934 to 35. And essentially, that's Chiang Kai-shek chasing them out of their previous heartland in Jiangxi, which is basically South Central China, and being made to walk thousands of miles up to the northwest of China, to a part of China that's so remote, so difficult to get to that they're safe. It's kind of like being forced out of Islington to go to the Northern Highlands. Well, some of us would love to go to the Northern Highlands. I think it's a fantastic idea, Tom. That sounds lovely, Tom.
中国北部，中北部，基本上是山西省，正如你在《历史余音》播客的另一期节目中所讨论的那样。他们被派去参加了1934年至1935年进行的“长征”。基本上，那是蒋介石把他们赶出他们在江西（基本上是华中南部）的前核心区，迫使他们步行数千英里来到中国西北部，来到一个如此偏远、如此难以到达以至于他们得以保全的地方。这有点像被强行赶出伊斯灵顿（Islington）去往北部高地（Northern Highlands）。嗯，我们有些人会很乐意去北部高地。我认为这是一个绝妙的主意，汤姆。听起来很不错，汤姆。
You're not suggesting, call it a difference between the two. But yes, actually, it's like, first of all, being kicked out of Islington, which is when the communists were in Shanghai, then being sent possibly to somewhere like Devon and realizing that they're coming to get you in Devon and then having to take a roundabout route that gets you to the Northern Highlands. But you're traveling via Wales and East Anglia, which is not the most obvious route. OK, right. OK, well, so that sets that up. So that gives us China in early 1937. And then what happens? 1937. And what happens then is in some ways best described by a brief entry from Chiang Kai-shek's diary. And I should say, by the way, here in a word on sources for all these questions, one of the most valuable and relatively recent documents that historians in this period have
你不是在暗示……好吧，这可以说是两者之间的区别。但是，是的，实际上，这就像，首先被踢出伊斯灵顿——当时共产党人在上海，然后可能被送到像德文郡（Devon）这样的地方，却意识到他们追到德文郡来抓你了，然后不得不经由一条绕远路的路线把你带到北部高地。但你是通过威尔士和东安格利亚（East Anglia）旅行的，这不是最显而易见的路线。好吧，对，好吧。那么这就把背景铺垫好了。这就为我们呈现了1937年初的中国。然后发生了什么？1937年。接下来发生的事情，在某种程度上最好用蒋介石日记中的一小段记载来描述。顺便说一下，在这里我要对所有这些问题的历史资料来源说一句话：在这个时期，历史学家能够接触到的最宝贵、相对较新的文件之一——直到2000年代初才真正得以接触——就是中国领导人蒋介石卷帙浩繁的日记，他从1917年左右一直写到20世纪70年代初。所以它们是一个极好的洞察窗口。显然，人们必须谨慎对待它们，但它们为了解他和周围其他人当时的想法提供了一个极好的窗口。在1937年夏天，紧张局势加剧，蒋介石和中国领导层一直在密切关注日本人的动向。这就是1937年7月7日这一天的背景。这基本上是中日战争史上可以被认为是——你知道的——斐迪南大公的汽车在萨拉热窝转过那个拐角的时刻。他是向左走？还是向右走？噢天哪，他向右走了。噢天哪，那里有个叫加夫里洛·普林西普（Gavrilo Princip）的家伙。天哪，他手里拿的是什么？我想这个故事可能广为人知。就中国而言，或许不那么广为人知的是，7月7日晚在北京郊外发生了什么，
been able to get access to, only since really the early 2000s, is the voluminous diaries of Chiang Kai-shek, China's leader, which he kept all the way from about 1917 up to the early 1970s. So they are a wonderful insight. Obviously, he had to treat it with caution, but they're a wonderful insight into what he and others were thinking around him. And in the summer of 1937, tensions heightened and Chiang Kai-shek and the Chinese leadership were keeping a close eye on what the Japanese were up to. So that is the context for the 7th of July, 1937. And this is essentially a date that in the history of China's war with Japan might be thought of as the moment when, you know, Archduke Ferdinand's car is rounding that corner in Sarajevo. Is he going to go left? Is he going to go right? Oh dear, he goes right. Oh dear, there's a chap called Gavrilo Princip there. And goodness me, what's he got in his hand? I think that story probably is quite well known. In the case of China, what's perhaps less well known is what happens on the outskirts of Beijing,
这个叫宛平的小村庄里。发生的事情是：我之前提到过的那些当地驻扎的日本军队部署之一——那些通过帝国强权安插在那里、处于中国主权领土上但被允许驻扎在那里的军队——正在点名，有两名士兵没有答到，他们的
this little village called Wanping on the evening of 7th of July. What happens is that one of those locally garrisoned Japanese troop deployments that I've mentioned, the ones that have been put there through imperial powers, they're on sovereign Chinese territory, but they're allowed to be there. They're taking roll call and a couple of the soldiers don't answer roll call and um their offer their commanding officer gets extremely worried stroke angry about this and thinks that what's happened is that local chinese warlord troops must have basically knocked a couple of them off for sport and he's not having any of it um it the missing soldiers actually do turn up the next morning and i think a slightly possibly embellished version of the story, but it may have something to it is that basically they popped off to have a pee. And they realized they'd missed roll call, they get into trouble. So they didn't actually report themselves back. So you might say that two soldierly bladders may have had something to do with the outbreak of World War II in China. But by that stage, things were beginning to spiral out of
指挥官对此感到极其焦虑兼愤怒，认为发生的事情一定是当地的中国军阀部队为了好玩而干掉了其中的两个士兵，他对此绝不罢休。失踪的士兵实际上在第二天早上确实出现了，一个可能略经美化但也许有其真实成分的版本是：他们两个其实是溜出去撒尿了。然后他们意识到自己错过了点名，要惹麻烦了。所以他们实际上并没有主动报告自己回来了。因此，你可以说，两个士兵的膀胱可能与中国抗日战争的爆发有某种关系。但在那个阶段，事情开始失控，因为基本上在向上汇报后，当地的日军说：“我们的士兵不见了。肯定是中国人干的。”中国人说：“这跟我们没关系。”基本上，双方爆发了对抗，日军指挥官随后说：“好吧，你知道的，我们绝不接受这一点。我们要求对北京这一地区的绝大部分领土拥有更多控制权，包括铁路枢纽。”这是一个非常非常重要的元素，因为谁控制了铁路，谁就能控制货运，就能控制军队的调动，当然，广义上讲，也能控制
control because essentially having reported up, the local Japanese troops said, we've lost these troops. Chinese must have done it. Chinese said it has nothing to do with us. And essentially, a confrontation occurred between the two sides in which the Japanese commanders then say, well, you know, we're not having any of this. And we demand much more control over much of the territory in this part of Beijing, including the railway junctions. And this is a really, really important element because whoever controls the railways can control freight, can control the transport of troops, and of course, can control communications,
中国北方那一地区的通讯。因此，这达到了一种程度，基本上情况被紧急上报给了南京的国民政府和蒋介石。我们该怎么办？在此之前，在过去的几年里，甚至在满洲入侵之后，蒋介石基本上奉行的是公开的不抵抗政策。在幕后，他在以各种方式袭扰日本人，但公开地说，我们不会被拉入冲突。这不是解决问题的办法，因为他知道那会有多么毁灭性。他在那天或第二天的日记中写道：这是与日本人对抗的时刻吗？
you know, broadly speaking, in that part of northern China. And so this reached a point where essentially it was flashed up to the national government, Chiang Kai-shek down in Nanjing. What are we going to do? And up to that point, for the previous few years, even after the invasion of Manchuria, Chiang Kai-shek had essentially operated a policy of public non-resistance. Behind the scenes, he was sort of harrying the Japanese in various ways, but publicly he was saying, we're not going to get pulled into a conflict. That's not the way to go because he knew how devastating it could be. And in his diary for that or the day after, he writes, is this the moment for confrontation with the Japanese?
这是转折点吗？所以他能看出，这个时刻或许就是某种极其毁灭性的事情将要发生的时刻。实际上，他身边的人、各种顾问都说：“听着，我们在中国根本没有足够的力量来真正与日本人作战。是的，我们有一支庞大的军队，但它是由军阀控制的。他们没有经过很好的训练。这基本上是一个农业社会。日本军队是高度机械化的。我们根本打不赢这场战争。”蒋介石想了想，说：“不，这一次，在经历了所有的挑衅、满洲事变、规模较小但仍然非常令人担忧的事件，以及现在最终对领土的新要求之后，在1937年
Is this the turning point? So he can see that this moment is maybe the moment at which something really devastating is going to happen. And he had people around him, actually, various advisors said, look, we're just not strong enough in China to actually fight the Japanese. Yes, we have a large army, but it's controlled by warlords. They're not well trained. It's largely agrarian society. The Japanese army is heavily mechanized. We just can't win this war. And Chiang Kai-shek thinks about it and says, no, this time, after all the provocations, after Manchuria, after smaller, but still very worrying incidents, and finally now this new demand for territory, in 1937,
7月，我们必须进行反击。”通过做出这个决定并召开最终做出决定的军事会议，他开启了这场冲突。这场冲突从北京郊外士兵之间的一场非常局部的摩擦，演变成了日本帝国与中华民国之间主权国家之间的战争。这就是两国之间冲突的开始。所以，拉纳，有些人可能会觉得这有违直觉，因为我们通常对中日战争的看法是日本对中国的侵略战争。但在某种程度上，你是在说蒋介石有意识地、刻意地选择接受卢沟桥事变带来的这种挑衅。他本可以忽略它。
in July, he says, we have to push back. And by making that decision and by holding a war council, which essentially takes the decision, he opens up the conflict, which moves from being a very local skirmish between these soldiers just outside Beijing, to becoming a war of nation states between the Japanese Empire and the Republic of China. And that is the beginning of the conflict between the two. So Rana, some people may find that counterintuitive, because the common way that we think about the Sino-Japanese War is a war of Japanese aggression against China. But in a way, you're saying that Chiang Kai-shek consciously, deliberately, chooses to accept this provocation of the Marco Polo Bridge. And he could have passed it up.
那么，是否存在这样一种另类的现实：他忽略了它，战争没有爆发？或者你认为战争有点像关于第一次世界大战的争论——实际上就是萨拉热窝的平行事件——战争无论如何都是不可避免地会到来吗？是的，这是一个很好的类比。同样，我想人们也可以问这样一个问题：对于1939年9月3日，内ville·张伯伦（Neville Chamberlain）本可以找到某种方法来摆脱对波兰的保证吗？或者到那个阶段这可能已经很困难了。总是有选择的。它们并不总是正确的选择，但必须做出选择。我认为
And is there an alternative reality, as it were, in which he does pass it up and the war doesn't break out? Or do you think war was a bit like the argument about the First World War, actually, the Sarajevo parallel? Was war coming inevitably anyway? Yes, it's a very good parallel. And again, one could, I suppose, ask the question, actually, for 3rd of September 39, you know, could Neville Chamberlain have found a way to perhaps get out of the Polish guarantee? Or that probably would have been difficult by that stage. There are always choices. They're not always the right choices, but they have to be made. I think
蒋介石当然认为战争显然会到来。如果当时不来，很快也会到来。而顾问们——像学者蒋文澜（音）这样经验丰富、深思熟虑且精通中国历史的人——当时在说，你知道的，给它到——我想他说过大约1940年，诸如此类。那是我们需要重新武装的时间。当然，欧洲也有关于重新武装的类似争论。问题在于，到这个阶段，我认为已经非常清楚了——而且日本军队本身也没有表现出任何其他迹象——其目标基本上是征服中国的很大一部分，也许不是作为正式的殖民化，而是扩大日本对中国已经非常非常巨大的控制权。如果他们夺取了那个铁路枢纽——那是37年7月那项特定决定的核心所在——那么基本上你就是在做一个决定：把中国北方拱手让给日本整整一代人。包括北京。整整一代人的北京。现在，那并不是他的首都，但从文化上讲，
that Chiang Kai-shek certainly thought that the war was clearly coming. And if it didn't come then, it would come very soon. And the advisors, people like the academic Jiang Wenlin, you know, very experienced and thoughtful guy who knew his Chinese history, was saying, you know, give it till, I think he said till about 1940, something like that. That's how long we'll need to rearm. And of course, there are similar arguments about rearmament in Europe as well. The problem is that by this stage, I think it was eminently clear, and certainly the Japanese themselves gave no indication otherwise, that the aim was essentially conquest of large parts of China, maybe not as formal colonization, but expanding the already very, very significant amount of control that China, so Japan had. And if they'd taken that railway junction, which was at the heart of the particular decision in July of 37, then essentially you do have a decision that you are handing over North China to Japan for a generation. Including Beijing. Including Beijing for a generation. Now, that's not where his capital was, but culturally,
把北京交给日本将是一个具有深刻象征意义和极其羞辱的时刻。那么拉纳，蒋介石开战的决定，基本上是这样的。共产党人对此态度如何？他们是否是其中的同谋？共产党人起初并不确定发生了什么，因为当然，他们将一切都视为更广泛的帝国主义阴谋的一部分。而且当然，他们正在接受斯大林的指示。但与此同时，他们也被要求表现得最好。我只需要简单地回溯几个月。
handing over Beijing to the Japanese would have been a deeply symbolic and deeply humiliating moment. And Rana, Cankocek's decision to go to war, basically. Yes. What is the attitude of the communists to this? And are they complicit in it? The communists at first aren't quite sure what's going on, because of course, they regard everything as being part of a wider imperialist conspiracy. And of course, they're getting instructions from Stalin. But at the same time, they've also been put on their best behavior. And I just need to go back briefly for a couple from Stalin. But at the same time, they've also been put on their best behavior. And I just need to go back briefly for a couple of months.
就在前一年年底，即1936年12月，出现了一些情况：蒋介石被几名军阀短暂绑架了。一个是满洲的少帅，另一个是一个叫杨虎城的人。这两位军阀基本上在西北中国的西安市绑架了他，把他关在一个别墅里——我的意思是，当这个人意识到自己即将被绑架时，慌乱中往山上跑，据他的假牙显然掉在了山坡上，不得不捡起来洗干净再放回嘴里。这些军阀基本上是在与共产党人合作，共产党人也急于将蒋介石置于他们的控制之下。当他被绑架的消息传来时，毛泽东和其他人的反应是：好吧，杀掉这家伙，你知道的，审判他并因他对中国人民犯下的罪行枪决他。
Right at the end of the previous year, in December 1936, circumstances emerged in which Chiang Kai-shek is kidnapped briefly by a couple of warlords. One was the young marshal of Manchuria, another one, a man called Yang Ho-chung. And these two warlords basically kidnap him in the city of xi'an in uh northwestern china hold him in a villa uh i mean you know the man when he sort of realized he was about to be kidnapped sort of caught running up a hill his false teeth had apparently fallen out onto the the hillside and had to be picked up and clean for put back in being put back in his mouth and these warlords are basically in uh collaboration with the communists who were also very keen to get chiang Kai-shek under their control. And when the news came in that he'd been kidnapped, the communists, Mao and others were like, well, let's kill the guy, you know, give him a trial and shoot him for his crimes against the Chinese people.
然后基本上一个非常大的人物介入了。这个人就是约瑟夫·斯大林，他对共产党人说“不”。你们不能这么做。原因很简单。考虑到我们这里谈论的时间，这是1936-1937年。苏联的红军正在经历巨大的清洗，而且它非常非常——你知道的——它还没有恢复到全盛状态。斯大林非常担心——他也确实应该担心——德国从西面、日本从东面发动进攻的可能性。对付其中一个就已经够受了。
And then basically a very big name steps in. And that guy is Joseph Stalin, who says no to the communists. You're not going to do this. And the reason is very simple. Bearing in mind what time we're talking about here, this is 1936-37. The Red Army in the Soviet Union is undergoing huge purges and it's very, very, you know, it's not at its full strength. Stalin is desperately worried as well he should be about the possibility of an attack from Germany on the western side and Japan on the east. One of those is enough to deal with.
两个同时来对苏联来说将是绝对致命的。他最不需要的就是蒋介石——这个在现阶段中国唯一具有信誉的国家级领导人——被干掉。那么谁来接管呢？嗯，也许是我们之前提到过的汪精卫，我们提到过他比蒋介石要亲日得多，至少在公众印象中是这样。
Two would be absolutely deadly for the Soviet Union. The last thing he needs is basically Chiang Kai-shek, who's the only credible leader that China has at a national level at this stage, being knocked off. And who takes over? Well, maybe Wang Jingwei, who we mentioned before, who we mentioned is much more pro-Japanese than Chiang Kai-shek, at least in public perception.
所以斯大林会允许中国共产党人干掉一个以反对外部势力——尤其是日本势力入侵——而闻名的领导人，转而让一个可能对这种入侵更加顺从的中国领导人上台吗？他当然不会这么做。因此，到了那个阶段，中国共产党人知道他们不可能把蒋介石从他的宝座上赶下来。但当1937年7月战争真正爆发时，他们很快就被以“统一战线”的形式拉入了讨论。那是当时使用的词汇。国民党人和共产党人举行了一次会议。他们派出了他们的一些最高领导人，基本上达成了一项协议。这种协议以这样或那样的形式持续了整个第二次世界大战，即在国家危机时期——
So is Stalin going to allow the Chinese communists to kill a leader who is well known for his opposition to outside forces, especially the Japanese, coming in and instead let in a Chinese leader who might be much more amenable to that? Of course, he's not going to do that. So by that stage, the Chinese communists know that they're not going to be in a position to knock Chiang Kai-shek off his perch. But when the war actually breaks out in July 1937, they're brought into discussions very, very quickly in a united front. That's the phrase that's used at the time. The nationalists and the communists have a meeting. They send some of their top leaders and essentially a deal is done. It lasts through in one form or another through the whole of the Second World War, which is that during the time of national crisis,
日本的入侵面前，中国的国民党人和共产党人，尽管他们彼此痛恨、势同水火，也将勉强合作共同抵抗日本。然后，当对日战争结束后，我们再看之后会发生什么。好吧。所以北京沦陷了。上海，上海发生了什么？北京在1937年夏天沦陷了，尽管它可能也不是很容易防守。我的意思是，它在几周内就沦陷了，拉纳。太不可思议了。这么大的一座城市。我的意思是，几周内就没了。那主要是在国民党中央军队的控制之下，因为基本上它是由包括孙桐萱和其他地方军阀在内的各种部队防守的——当我们说军阀军队时，你知道，我们在这里谈论的不是那种训练有素、随时准备上战场、
the invasion by Japan, China's nationalists and communists, much that they hate each other, daggers drawn and all of that, will uneasily work together to oppose the Japanese. And then when the war against Japan is over, then we see what happens after that. Yeah. Okay. So Beijing falls. Shanghai, what happens in Shanghai? Beijing falls in summer of 1937, although it probably wasn't very easily defensible either. I mean, it fell within weeks, Prana. Extraordinary. Such a huge city. I mean, just gone within a couple of weeks. that was primarily under nationalist central army control uh because essentially it was defended by troops of various people including sung joe yuan and other local warlords who when we say warlord armies you know we're not here talking about the kind of superbly trained battlefield ready um soldiers that japan had managed to put together by the stage we're talking about okay peasant boys
日本在这个阶段已经设法组建起来的士兵。我们谈论的是……好吧，被从农村抓来的农家子弟，通常并不是很想呆在那里。是的，那些部队没能守住北京。上海则不同。上海是蒋介石选择死守的地方。所以我提到战争是在中国北方的北京周边爆发的。但蒋介石决定，好吧，既然战争已经开始，那么我们需要开辟第二战场。第二战场于1937年8月在伟大的港口城市上海迅速开辟，该市位于中国东海岸更靠南的地方。蒋介石这样做有几个原因。其中之一是世界各地的记者都在那里。我的意思是，你在本播客的开头提到过他与艾舍伍德（Isherwood）和奥登（Auden），他们于1937-38年一起在中国，写了一本名为《战地行》（Journey to a War）的精彩图书，讲述了他们在
brought out of the countryside often not very keen to be there. And yes, those troops were not able to hold Beijing. Shanghai was different. And Shanghai was where Chiang Kai-shek chose to make a stand. So I mentioned the war opened in northern China around Beijing. But Chiang Kai-shek decided, well, if the war's beginning, then we need to open up a second front. And the second front was opened up rapidly in August 1937 in the great port city of Shanghai, much further to the south on the eastern coast of China. And Chiang Kai-shek did it for a couple of reasons. One is that the world's press was there. I mean, you started this podcast with that he and Isherwood and Auden, who were there together in China in 1937-38, wrote a wonderful book called Journey to a War, which is about their
当时中国经历。所以来自西方的形形色色的人都在关注发生的事情。奥登、伟大的战地摄影师罗伯特·卡帕（Robert Capa）当时在中国拍下了他最精的一些照片。许多人直接从当时已经肆虐了一年的西班牙战争赶来。这大概对蒋介石保持中国在国际上的关注至关重要。在公众视野中。当时，在中国人和其他人心中，
experiences in China from that time. So all sorts of people from the West were watching what was happening. Auden, the great war photographer Robert Capa, took some of his finest photos in China at that time. Many people came straight from the war in Spain, which had already been raging for a year at that stage. And this is presumably really important for Chiang to keep China in the global eye. In the public view. At that time, in the mind of the Chinese and others,
西班牙内战和中国抗日战争被视为进步硬币的两面。像奥登和艾舍伍德这样的人也倾向于这样认为。他们明确表示过他们去过西班牙然后又来到了中国。在当时人们的心中，这两者是联系在一起的，而在现在，这种说法已经不那么常见了。所以，宣传是一个原因。但另一个原因与军队训练有关。
the Spanish Civil War and the Chinese war against Japan were regarded as two sides of the progressive coin. And people like Auden and Isherwood tend to think so as well. They were explicit about the fact that they've been in Spain and then in China. The two went together in minds then, in then where it isn't so commonly heard now. So the publicity is one reason. But another reason is to do with troop training.
西班牙内战和中国抗日战争被视为进步硬币的两面。奥登和伊舍伍德等人也倾向于这么认为。他们明确表示他们去过西班牙，然后又去了中国。这两者在当时人们的心中是联系在一起的，而在现在则不那么常见了。所以宣传是一个原因。但另一个原因与军队训练有关。
The best troops that China had, Chiang Kai-shek's finest troops, were essentially stationed in and around Shanghai. And they had been trained by actually some of the best German commanders, Hans von Sigt and then Alexander von Falkenhausen, who had been brought in as German military advisors to Chiang Kai-shek's armies in the 1930s. And the historian Hans van der Ven has written in great detail about the amazing detail of how these troops were actually retrained. So China did have its own core of modernized troops, but they were a relatively very small number of the millions who were recruited overall. And Chiang, I think, would have hoped that they would have been able to hold Shanghai for as long as possible. And indeed, they did hold out for about three months in Shanghai. But Shanghai turned into a city that was a battlefield. Trenches were literally dug in the streets of Shanghai, not in the French concession and not in that international settlement that we mentioned earlier, because those areas were
中国当时最好的军队，蒋介石的精锐部队，基本上都驻扎在上海及其周边地区。他们实际上是由一些最优秀的德国指挥官训练的，包括汉斯·冯·塞克特，后来还有亚历山大·冯·法肯豪森，他们在20世纪30年代被请来担任蒋介石军队的德国军事顾问。历史学家方德万曾详细撰文讲述了这些部队如何被重新训练的惊人细节。所以中国确实有自己的核心现代化部队，但与整体征召的数百万士兵相比，他们的数量非常少。我认为，蒋介石原本希望他们能够尽可能长时间地守住上海。事实上，他们在上海也确实坚持了大约三个月。但上海变成了一座战场城市。上海的街道上真的挖出了战壕，当然不是在法租界，也不是我们前面提到的那个公共租界，因为这些区域是
neutral, because of course, they were run by foreigners, they weren't under Chinese sovereignty. But you could look from your tea time terrace at the Cathay Hotel, in the international settlement, almost, or the rooftop anyway, and see the fighting going on just across the city border in the Chinese controlled area, which in the words of Orden looked like a moonscapecape because it was being so heavily bombed. And although the more than 100,000 Chinese troops who were fighting there fought very, very valiantly, commemorated actually in a movie that was a big hit in China and briefly released in the UK a couple of years ago called The 800, which is about the last stand of some of those Chinese soldiers in a warehouse on the riverbank of Shanghai. Eventually, by November of 1937,
中立的，因为它们是由外国人管理的，不属于中国主权管辖。但是你可以在公共租界的华懋饭店的下午茶露台上，或者至少从屋顶上，看到就在一河之隔的中国控制区内发生的战斗。用奥登的话说，那里看起来就像月球表面一样，因为它遭到了极其猛烈的轰炸。尽管在那里战斗的十多万中国军队打得非常非常英勇，几年前中国一部大热并在英国短暂上映的电影《八佰》就纪念了这一事迹，讲的就是其中一部分中国士兵在上海河畔的一座仓库里做最后的坚守。最终，到了1937年11月，
they were defeated, many of them had been killed, and the Chinese troops as a whole were ordered to retreat from Shanghai because it was simply no longer defensible. But it became the first really public major battle of the Chinese war against Japan. And so Shanghai falls to Japanese takeover. That's right. In November 1937, Shanghai is captured by the Japanese. Again, not the foreign-controlled areas
他们被打败了，许多人阵亡了，中国军队整体接到命令撤出上海，因为那里实在已经无法防守。但这成为了中国抗日战争中真正意义上的第一场公开的大规模战役。于是上海落入了日本人的掌控。没错。1937年11月，上海被日军攻陷。同样，外国控制区并没有沦陷
which don't fall until Pearl Harbor, but essentially by that stage, by the end of 1937, beginning of 1938, Shanghai and much of the area around it is in Japanese hands. And the Chinese nationalists, Chiang Kai-shek and his government and much of the army have shipped downriver 800 miles to the southwestern city of Chongqing,
直到珍珠港事件爆发时才沦陷，但基本上到那个阶段，即1937年底到1938年初，上海及其周边的大部分地区都落入了日本人手中。中国国民党人、蒋介石及其政府以及大部分军队已经顺江而下800英里，撤到了西南部城市重庆，
known in the West at that time often as Chongqing, which became the temporary wartime capital of China from 1937 all the way up to 1946. And the war, from their point of view, moves inland. So Rana, that seems like the perfect place to break. Because of course, next in their sights is the capital, isn't it? Nanjing. And many of our listeners will know that things don't unfold well for the people in Nanjing. But we will come back to that next time in our next episode. So thank you very much, Rana, and we'll see you all next time.
当时在西方通常被称为Chungking，它成为了中国从1937年一直到1946年的战时临时首都。从他们的角度来看，战争向内陆转移了。那么，拉娜，这似乎是一个完美的暂停切入点。因为当然，他们下一个盯上的目标就是首都，对吧？南京。我们的许多听众都知道，南京人民的遭遇并不好。但我们将在下一次的节目中再来探讨这个话题。非常感谢你，拉娜，我们下次节目再见。
Look forward to that. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment
期待那一期。再见。再见。感谢收听《历史余音》。想要获取独家节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐余音》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦绯闻的地方，在我们的问答环节中，我们将为你揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱
and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及优先购买现场门票，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。这期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。